when the 21 year old Prince performed on
American Bandstand host Dick Clark told
him that the song he just played wasn't
the kind of music that comes from
Minneapolis Minnesota yeah I mean this
is not the kind of music that comes from
Minneapolis Minnesota I'm in Minneapolis
my hometown to meet with jellybean
Johnson one of the pioneers of the
electro funk style known as the
Minneapolis sound that's nasty la that's
nasty we're gonna prove big part wrong I
need to get some shiny joints like the
sequin biddies okay here we go
the Minneapolis sound is all about
fusion not only of genres but a black
and white musical taste the style
changed the course of pop in the 80s
with print and influenced artists like
Jenny Jack's it can still be heard in
pop music today I was blessed to work
with a Minneapolis music legend
jellybean Johnson to create a
Minneapolis sound inspired track so he's
back in the day I would have played it
like that so straight I would play like
this yeah yeah this man is the real deal
he was the drummer for the Minneapolis
band a time he also worked with
legendary production team Jimmy Jam and
Terry Lewis and he even produced one of
my favorite Minnesota bands of all time
in conditions
[Music]
but first to understand what the
Minneapolis sound is we have to look at
where it came from most people
immediately think of prints when they
think of the Minneapolis sound and
there's a good reason
there's 1980 hit album dirty mind put
the style on the map it's the only cat I
knew that could take two strings and it
sounds y-you know it's B big as a house
you know the rhythm would be big as a
house think about the rhythm guitar
controversy okay it's like two strings
[Music]
controversy and kiss are the blueprint
of that kind of stuff you listen to his
rhythm plan but how did the sound evolve
in the relative isolation of Minneapolis
to answer that we have to start with the
music career of another Prince Prince
Rodgers Prince Rogers was the stage name
of John Lewis Nelson Prince's father
Nelson was one of the many black
musicians who migrated to the Twin
Cities in the 20th century from the
south many of them settled here in my
neighborhood north Minneapolis there's
my high school but North High Poehler's
let's get it they brought with them an
expertise in black genres like blues
gospel and jazz Minneapolis had also
long been home to other musical
traditions from the poe+ of European
settlers to the Dinkytown folk music
circuit where Bob Dylan will get his
start
but segregation kept the black and white
music scenes mostly separate during the
mid 20th century in Minneapolis if a
club became too black the police would
find the reason to shut it down but that
didn't stop local black soul and funk
bands like Maurice McKinney's in the
champion's Hayes prophets of peace jelly
beans first band flight time and of
course Prince's first band Grand Central
from creating a local black music scene
but because the black population in
Minneapolis was still relatively small
these musicians were absorbing and
playing other genres like folk rock and
roll and pop my mom will be here in 1968
to keep me out of the gangs in Chicago
I came from Chicago and I was around you
know black radio all the time and so
when I got here we didn't have black ray
we've like ready it was only on for like
four hours
and so that mean I had to listen to the
white rock stations and you know the
three dog nights and rare herbs and like
Sabbath and that's you know a young
black kid that you know I was kind of
different you know yeah I found out I
started to like it you know so it
changed me musically to these eclectic
influences merged on princess third
album dirty mind which introduced the
Minneapolis sound Rolling Stone called
dirty mind one of the most radical 180
degree turns in pop history the album
was over the top both in the stylization
and it's highly sexual lyrics dirty mind
found crossover appeal on a national
level by appealing not only to a funk
and R&B fans but also to punk rock and
new wave crowds in the early 80s the
Minneapolis nightclub First Avenue was
exploding with a mix of music to punk
bands like hüsker dü and the
replacements we're making a name for
themselves playing the club's smaller
dirtier stage at the 7th Street entry
while Prince was packing a larger main
room stage next door Prince used this
club to try out new music by slipping
unreleased recordings to the DJ and
watching the crowd react and when he was
ready for his feature film debut he used
First Avenue as the band battleground in
the film Purple Rain he was a master
larren funky guitar parts you know and
he put him in this subtly you just hear
him back in the back they be booing you
know got all this other stuff going on
he was a master that that guitar playing
a lady cabdriver the rhythm man go back
listen to that that's crazy
that's Minneapolis
that's crazy so on musical terms what is
the Minneapolis sound some key
ingredients include highly processed
instruments especially drums
and using sympathizers where prior bans
may have used horns as kids you know I
was lucky I was in flight time and we
had like five horns well Chris was in
Grande City where they'd have horns that
he heard our horns and he said well we
don't have a horn section I know I he's
cocky well how long but you know what
I'm gonna fix that
what's flight time in Grand Central
those were so separated we were like man
we like rival bands at 15 years old
though okay Prince's dirty mine wasn't a
blowout success in terms of record sales
but it paved the way for other bands to
develop the sound one of the first and
most successful was jelly beans van the
time
[Music]
the Minneapolis been led by Mars day was
created by Prince in 1981 like much of
princes work the times music was
danceable funky highly processed and new
synthesizers
but unlike Prince who was known for his
androgynous style the times image was
all about dressing immaculately with
exotic suits slick haircuts in shine
shoes in the mid-80s two members of the
time Jimmy Jam and Terry Lewis broke
away to create their own production
company flight time productions over the
next decade they helped take the
Minneapolis sound platinum with massive
hits like Janet Jackson's album control
which they produced and helped to write
jellybean Johnson also worked with Jimmy
and Terry helping Janet rock even harder
with her 1989 hit black cat
[Music]
black cap you know it tripped out all
the heavy metal guys but that's what I
was listening to you know and so I got
some of my friends and rented a Marshall
out coming up real loud kicked everybody
out the Minneapolis sound of the 80s and
90s helped turn the Twin Cities of
Minneapolis and st. Paul into a great
place to be a musician the music didn't
stop when Prince died there's a dynamic
and diverse local music scene where an
artist like Liz Oh can perform with a
range of musicians all while discovering
her voice all right so for this
Minneapolis track that we created
I had jellybeans laid down three
separate layers of guitar so here's the
first joint that's the first layer now
first and secondly are put together
third layer of the B section when we go
to the floor let's play it by yourself
cuz it's actually where the flavor is
that's what a flavor it's so simple for
so necessary the the cool part about it
is it's tiny little parts all added
together as like a big puzzle to make
one soundscape down here we have some
keyboard parts that have different roles
in the track as well some of these parts
act like horn parts like right here
brass since I'm solo it just so you can
hear it one two that's like a horn line
I was listening to a bunch of mors day
at a time a bunch of prints I realized
that they weren't playing these
full-bodied chords but it was more so
about the rhythm in it
bleeb it's simple step away from it come
back better than a simple that's kind of
how I use that sense right there for the
horns I'm not a p.m. I'm not a pianist
I'm not a keys player at all but I feel
like you know the soul is there the
is there the vibe is there and that's
really what the music was about love the
feel all together this is what it sounds
like
[Music]
the Minneapolis sound did more for the
cultures and just leave an imprint on
top 40 music it is a unique fusion of
genres that help break down barriers not
only between musical traditions but also
between different racial communities
although Minneapolis is still no racial
utopia the Minneapolis sound has brought
different people together on the dance
floor for decades
[Music]
well the PBS video app is your home for
amazing educational shows ranging from
science films on Nova to music from
Austin City Limits to documentaries from
Ken Burns and frontline all with no ads
or algorithms oh it sounds field we're
there too if you live in the u.s. check
out the link in our description to start
watching anytime on nearly any device
[Music]